qu'on va partir maintenant à la chasse
aux orthodoxes avec info ou intox
antoine fenaux beau soir bonsoir droit
au menu ce soir plusieurs fois que la
première elle concerne des réfugiés
ukrainien oui absolument et ce n'est pas
la première fois que ça s'est produit on
en avait déjà parlé ici info ou intox
mais la fox en question vous allez le
voir elle part de cette photo plutôt de
ces deux photos elles ont beaucoup
circulé sur twitter notamment en tchèque
en espagnol mais aussi en polonais ces
photos vous les voulez vous les voyez on
voit quoi une devanture d'un magasin et
vous apercevez cette petite pancarte
convoi accroché au mur qu'est ce qu'on
voit une sorte de drapeau ukrainien avec
une main et la légende du tweet nous
livre ce qu'il y aurait de contenus sur
cette pancarte set je vous le traduit
des inscriptions 10 interdit aux
ukrainiens les vendeurs et les gérants
disent avoir en avoir marre des vols et
des comportements épouvantable de ces
personnes des photos dont qui auraient
été prises à prague en république
tchèque des photos et c'est peut-être
plus inquiétant qui ont également été
reprise par un journal de prague le
prague morning vous l'apercevez ici vous
voyez ici une capture d'écran car le
tweet a été supprimée là aussi on va y
revenir les deux magasins eux se nomme
inside et tunku csaky carline alors
voilà pour les photos mais ce que les
magasins existait ce que ces pots carte
existe et c'est toute la question alors
oui ces magasins exister pour s'en
rendre compte il suffit simplement de se
rendre sur l'outil tout le monde connaît
sur google maps est effectivement moi
j'ai assez très facilement retrouver
l'inde est l'un de ces deux concours
tchèque et carline vous le voyez on
retrouve ici la devanture que l'on
reconnaît bien sur la photo que je vous
ai montré un petit peu un petit peu
avant il faut dire que les médias les
médias tchèques choqué parce que ces
photos montraient se sont rendus sur
place pour savoir eh bien s'il y avait
ou pas ces fameuses photos
les deux magasins donc je vous disais
sont situés dans le nord de prague et
les médias tchèques y sont allés et ils
ont interrogé les propriétaires de ces
magasins ce média nous dit qu'ils n'ont
jamais vu de pancartes qui n'ont jamais
affiché ses pancartes à noter également
qu'une un autre média tchèque lui a
réalisé un petit un petit reportage vous
le voyez ici où ils ont interrogé les
deux propriétaires de ces de ces deux
enseignes qui n'ont jamais affiché
évidemment ces pancartes et qui
témoignent c'est un photomontage dit
l'un d'entre eux vient de palestine donc
je sais ce que signifie la guerre j'ai
perdu beaucoup d'amis et de la famille
je ne peux pas être contre l'ukraine
c'est une catastrophe à noter que le
journal prague morning dont je vous ai
montré le tweak qui a été supprimé à
publier ses excuses après avoir relayé
ces photos qui sombrait simplement
fausse nous info ou intox on a réussi à
retrouver la source de ces images et de
cette photo et la voici il s'agit d'une
jeune chaîne télégramme pro-russe comme
par hasard intel cela va vous reconnais
vous reconnaissez le petit z à côté du
nom de la chaîne ces photos donc elles
ont été publiées ici c'était le 26 mai
dernier on retrouve donc les mêmes
photos truquées avec ce commentaire
repris par le tweed que je vous ai
montré au début de mon intervention
conclusion aucune un fox pro-russe de
plus qui vise la discréditer des
réfugiés ukrainien bon alors personne
n'est à l'abri donc autre aveugle vont
vous vouliez nous parler elle concerne
aussi les réfugiés ukrainien mais en
bulgarie oui en bulgarie absolument et
c'est cette vidéo que vous voyez ici une
courte vidéo elle a beaucoup circulé sur
twitter notamment sur ce compte elle a
été visionnée plus de 30 mille fois
voyez le petit compteur en bas de la
vidéo on y voit quoi des familles avec
des bagages en main visiblement en train
de quitter un lieu lui le tweet au
dessus et explicite l'amour de l'union
européenne est terminée les réfugiés
ukrainiens doivent partir la bulgarie a
annoncé l'expulsion de 35 mille réfugiés
des hôtels de la mer noire alors nous
info ou intox et vu qu'on est un peu
sceptique on a tapé dans google
ukrainien bulgarie et hôtels tout ça en
bulgare et on tombe sur plusieurs
articles de la presse bulgare dont que
celui là ceux du média ou ian vous le
voit si vous le voyez qui explique que
ces réfugiés ukrainien qui était jusqu'à
présent hébergés dans des hôtels
touristiques sur les bords de la bernois
aider ils vont être relogés dans des
centres temporaires en raison du début
de la saison touristique c'est un lieu
effectivement de villégiature bien connu
les bords de la mer noire il commence à
faire chaud de quoi provoquer quelques
tensions sur les sucres et les
ukrainiens nous dit d'ailleurs le
journal bulgare cas il ne voulait pas
être déplacés l' agence de presse
bulgare bta de son côté une donne les
détails depuis 31 mai ces réfugiés sont
relogés dans des centres temporaires
dans l'arrondissement de zara fauveau
sur la mer noire est elle aux veaux ces
deux villes sont situées sur le sud est
de la bulgarie prenez logement des
réfugiés dans ces hôtels était donc une
lure temporaire nous disent les
autorités alors voilà pour le contexte
est votre vidéo alors allez vite dément
et vous êtes pointilleuse et vous avez
bien raison la chaire audrey nous
l'avons retrouvée figurez-vous cette
vidéo est la voix si elle provient de
cette chaîne telegraph du bulbe du
médias bulgares ou niall dont je vous ai
montré l'arctique un peu avant on trouve
effectivement la même séquence vous
l'apercevez ici avec une citation un peu
en dessous du ministre des affaires
étrangères ukrainien dont je voulais la
traduction des réfugiés chrétiens se
trouvant en bulgarie ont commencé à être
relogés dans les hôtels situés à côté de
la mer noire sa cote dock avec le
contexte qu'on évoquait oleg nikolaenko
qui est précise et donc c'est son nom
aux médias ukrainiens les motifs de ces
de sérologie donc ces réfugiés chrétiens
qui vont être orientées vers des
dortoirs conclusion pas d'expulsion de
réfugiés l'ukrainien mais une
réinstallation et d'autres structures
d'accueil merci beaucoup antoine fenaux
vous restez avec nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour la suite de
ce paris direct
[Musique]